hello everyone and welcome to what could
only be described as the the craziest
game of the championship at least so far
this game is um uh pretty much every
move they make the other player uh is
completely winning uh Magnus makes a
move a rapper is completely winning
rapper makes a move Magnus is completely
winning then one of the players is
completely destroyed and you can't
believe that
um uh you know from that position one of
the players will not lose and yet that's
exactly what happens now of course it's
Blitz
bigger part of the game was played only
with a few seconds on the clock but this
game is wow uh let's dive straight into
it Magnus Carlsen versus Rapport Magnus
opens with D4 we have E6 by rapper going
for the Horowitz defense but Magnus
switches it up with E4 and transposes
into the French defense so D5 we have
Knight to the C3 and Bishop to B4 rapid
goes for the winiver variation and you
know that this is going to be a fun game
uh the reason of course the the French
is always fun and another thing a report
is one of the players who plays the most
exciting chess of all the players in the
world today so E5 Magnus advances the
pawn and pawn to C5 this is the the
standard way to counter this A3 Bishop
captures B captures and queen to C7 uh
we have H4 there are other moves that
are more popular but nowadays H4
especially in in faster time formats is
gaining a lot in popularity Knight E7
and now the immediate H5 taking away the
G6 Square from the Knight also you wanna
play H6 as soon as possible so H6 by
Rapport Knight to F3 and now Pawn to B6
with Bishop to B5 check Bishop to D7 and
now Magnus Retreats with Bishop to D3
Fantasy 4 Bishop back to E2 and now
Bishop to A4 uh very standard idea uh
when playing the French preventing white
from executing A4 because if white
executes A4 then he also gets the A3
Square for the bishop and for the moment
this dark Square Bishop doesn't have
that many great squares so Bishop to f
for and now Knight to A6 uh we have
Queen uh there is a game where G4 was
played but here Magnus goes for Queen to
D2 and it is now as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game so Robert
Castle's Queen side and now when you
look at this position you're probably
asking yourself or even when you're
playing against this type of French
you're asking yourself what is there to
do like there's nothing you can do here
you you can't attack the queen side uh
the center is completely closed do you
do something on the king side what what
is there to do well in order to achieve
something in close structures of the
French especially the uh this one you
have to sacrifice something so if Magnus
wants to win he's gonna have to
sacrifice and that of course will allow
a report winning chances as well so
first a magnet starts by re-maneuvering
the Knight sorry to E3 we have King to
B7 improving the position of the king
Knight to F1 we have Queen to D7 and now
Knight the E3 uh we have Knight to C7
and now King the F1 uh and here Robert
could decide maybe to strike right away
with Ponto G5 but he first wants to put
pieces on uh as optimal squares as
possible with G3 and now Queen to E8 we
have King to G2 and now Queen to G8 now
uh probably preparing G5 uh Rook a to B1
by Magnus and now comes Queen to H7 and
this queen to H7 is a very very annoying
move as Magnus would very much love to
sacrifice something here just to open a
blinds towards the black king but now
with the Knight on E3 stuck guarding the
C2 Pawn is it's not as simple so Bishop
to F3 puts the bishop on this diagonal
and of course a rapport immediately
brings the king back when of Queen to E2
again putting more pressure on the
central pawns and now Rook the C8 and
now Rook the B2 so now the pawn is
defended and Rapport has to really worry
about Magnus sacrificing something if
that doesn't happen there's really
nothing to do here so Knights the B5
rapper puts pressure on the C3 pawn and
this gives Magnus an idea now one way
uh you could go about this is to
sacrifice The Exchange immediately and
just get rid of that Knight and then
bring the other Rook into the game but
Magnus decides to go for Knight captures
on D5 this stops the threat of Knight to
C3 as for the moment your knight guards
the pawn but now e captures and D5 and
now Magnus should eliminate this Knight
but he goes for E6 with check and this
is where the game explodes completely
now a report is completely winning and
he goes King to B7 uh we have e captures
and F7 by Magnus and now Queen to F5 an
extremely powerful move by Rapport uh
and the the question is what can magnets
do here in order to at least try try to
survive Magnus goes Rook to B4 he
attacks the bishop here but now Knight
captures on V4 eliminating that Rook we
have Queen to E7 with check Magnus uh
wins this e file for himself also the C7
Pawn is defended so you can't block or
rather you should block after Knight the
C7 there isn't all that much format to
do he's going to have to capture back
material and then let's say rook hdf8
and black is just black is just
spectacular here you don't have to worry
about the Knight you don't have to worry
about the D5 Pawn the queen is guarding
that so this is perfectly fine however
King the A6 was played by Robert and
this does give Magnus chances but he
should play a captures on V4 and put a
rook on A1 makes sense but here the
players were again extremely low on time
so Queen characters can be four by
Magnus and now we have Bishop captures
on C2 we have A4 Magnus continues the
attack on the queen side and now uh
Knight back to C7 here at Knight
captures on C3 should be played it's a
weird move but it does give it up or the
fast Pawn here and after Queen captures
you will play Bishop to E4 very nice
Bishop captures Queen captures let's F3
check Queen E2 check and uh black has
really nothing to worry about his up
material he he has a pass C Pawn this is
completely winning but that's easier
said than done when you have a few
seconds on the clock so night the C7 was
played Bishop captures and C7 and now
Bishop to E4 now threatening Queen
captures on F3 Magnus plays Bishop back
to F4 and now look at this bishop
captures with check King captures and
queen to e for check now rap would
sacrifice some material but he will win
the Rook on H1 King to G4 by Magnus and
now uh Rapport if he wants to play this
for a win he should play Queen to E6
check let's say queen T6 checking F3 and
then bring the king back to avoid
getting himself in trouble and now the
game continues rapper still have
material still a better position uh not
an easy one of course the the control
with the little time on the clock but
that's what you should do however in the
game Queen captures an H1 was played and
now it's Magnus who will be pushing for
the win Queen to B5 with check King to
B7 and now Pawn to A5
uh with all sorts of nasty ideas like
Queen to D7 is always a worry A6 check
is always a worry and uh the only move
that does not lose the game for Rapport
is G6 it's really weird that they even
consider such a move uh with all all the
action happening on the queen side uh
but here Rapport would actually be
threatening mate in one and Magnus would
have to react to this even after some
sort of a check here let's say King 8
you will have to capture and then uh
okay now you have H5 an option you can
play Queen to E4 uh not easy to uh to
defend uh against this let's say Pawn to
G7 even this you don't care H5 check
King to H for and now look at this queen
E6 and uh rapper just wins you don't
care about any captures or anything
because this will be Checkmate in order
to stop Checkmate you will have to play
Pawn to F3 now let's say Rook H the d8
and now even f8 Queen it doesn't really
matter you just eliminate that give up a
rook captures let's say queen into the
game uh Rook captures and you get this
position where black is just up material
and the white king is in a terrible
terrible position so black king isn't in
a great position but it's not easy
getting to that black king with the real
controlling the back crank and with uh
the D5 Pawn being defended uh not gonna
happen so instead after A5 Rook H the d8
was played by erichard and now Magnus
has Pawn to A6 with check King to A8 and
now uh look at this uh Magnus plays f8
Queen he wants to get rid of The Rook
from the control of the D7 Square so he
can play Queen 37 Queen to B7 Checkmate
however the only win the only move that
wins here is Ponta F3 and a completely
crazy stuff but now how do you continue
with black if you try now G6 you want to
get a H5 into the game just H captains
H5 King F5 and now after some Queen H3
check King F6 and there's no uh playing
this with black you don't have any
useful checks and the pawns will now win
the game however Magnus tried f8 Queen
and well this does uh remove Rooks
control over the D7 Square it also sets
up The Rook for this Rook captures on F4
but the dad Bishop was a wonderful
attacker for Magnus so Rook captures an
f8 Queen D7 now threatening Checkmate
and now Rook captures an F4 the only
move that wins the game for rapper G
captures an F4 and now Queen to G2 check
and now of course with the king and
queen being so close to each other you
know that a million check is about to
happen million checks so King H4 Queen
H2 sorry not Queen H2 Queen first
captures an F2 check King G4 Queen to G2
check engage for now G5 with check H
characters and G6 now Queen H2 check
King to G4 and H5 with check King F3 and
now Queen to H1 with check King F2 Queen
to H4 with check King F3 Queen to G4
with check uh and now uh a queen trade
is forced Queen captures H captors and
King captures on G4 and now a report is
up a full Rook Magnus does have the two
connected past pawns but a full Rook is
a full rook and the Rapport plays the
only winning move Pawn to B5 he wants to
play B4 bust open the position here and
then Advance his C Pawn to Victory or
promote the beep onto a seep on it and
then win that way so F5 look at this B4
F6 B captures and C3 both players
playing absolute uh top moves F7 C2 and
now G7 by Magnus so you know that Magnus
is getting a queen as well C1 a rapper
brings the queen into the game and f8
queen Magnus also brings the queen into
the game but the problem is uh Rapport
is still up a rook even with the pawn so
close to promoting a report starts
checking the white king queen to G1
check King H5 Queen to HD check King to
G6 Queen to G3 check King H6 Queen to H
for check King to G6 and now Queen to G4
check King H6 Magnus forces are upwards
to figure out something otherwise he's
gonna run out of time and Rapport plays
Pawn to C3 and still a wrapper
completely winning we have Queen to F7
now Magnus threatens Checkmate but also
the D5 Pawn is hanging so how do you
deal with this queen to H4 with check we
have King to G6 now Queen to E4 with
check uh interestingly here apple has a
forced mate like Rook to C6 check King
to F5 and now you can just play Queen F2
check pick up the White Queen and that's
it but of course with a few seconds on
the clock uh you really don't have time
to uh think about this so uh Queen to E4
check was played we have King to G5 and
now the only move that wins the game for
Rapport is Rook to B8 because now the
queen defends the D5 Pawn Rook the B8
stops Queen to B7 Checkmate and now you
just continue pushing your pass Pawn to
Victory pretty much that's it so after
King G5 Queen the E3 check was played
but now Queen H5 and no longer is the
position winning for upper now it should
uh end up in a draw but Rapport has to
just continue checking the the white
king but he wanted to win this and he
played Queen to E8 which is sort of
winning uh now the queen cannot move as
the queen is Spin To The King and H5 and
it seems there is nothing for Magnus to
do but there is one thing he can do he
can find the winning idea win the game
so feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for Magnus while I give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this I
mean uh the the the biggest slap in the
face possible for Rapport he was not not
uh prepared for this uh and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it
is G8 Queen and now uh even though it
seems like you are winning so much
material with black uh the problem is
once you capture the queen uh you are no
longer pinning uh here and then Queen to
B7 is Checkmate so this is now
impossible and uh there's nothing for
you to do if you capture this queen we
just capture Queen captures on F7 and
now again we're threatening Checkmate
and we have a full queen against The
Rook it doesn't matter uh that this past
Pawn is here because you have to defend
against Checkmate and then the queen
just picks up the pawn nothing to it so
instead after G8 Queen now rapper's only
chance is the sort of Checkmate the
white king or even find the Perpetual uh
Queenie to check we have Queen to G4 now
now Magnus has two queens to help out
with the defense Rook the h8 with check
Kink the G5 and now Queen to E3 with
check King F6 Queen to H6 would check
King to E7 and now you can't even go for
this Rook H7 to win the queen because
this is Checkmate so here after uh king
t7 queen to C6 was played uh sort of
trying to maybe now start pushing the
the pawn to Victory but now just Queen G
to G8 check and that's it it was in this
position on move 71 that uh uh uh uh
resigned in the game as there is nothing
more to be done here I'm just gonna
check maybe it's uh
yeah it's after Queen to G8 I wasn't
sure if he resigned here yeah after
Queen G2 G8 he resigned the game there's
nothing more to be done here uh because
if you capture then the only move to
defend Checkmate is Queen to see it or
queen to E8 and both moves are met by
Queen captures Checkmate the pawn covers
B7
wow wow what a game what a game like uh
the the the the end it's like the
uh I mean it's like the the engine went
back and forth like uh you know the bar
the engine went back and forth like like
a ping pong ball it was absolutely
incredible to watch and I can't even
imagine the the stress the players were
uh feeling when when playing this game
uh when Magnus finally won he uh you
could see on his face that he could not
believe that he just won this game that
was I mean and not only that
um as he car went into the second day
with a full point lead and Magnus won
the two against in the second day Hikaru
drew the two games now Magnus catches up
to Hikaru and it's once again a Race So
it is possible that we will have a
Magnus Hikaru playoff uh everything else
is possible as well but that would be
just the icing uh or the topping on the
kick yeah uh sure that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh in my opinion
definitely the craziest game of the of
both rapid and Blitz so far we'll see
what happens in the other rounds uh so
you know let's hope we get more games
like this uh so yeah I really hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank uh
Michael zacarius Chris
John Henry and Rafael Zamora for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
wonderful event until it finishes uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day